hello and welcome to the reason live
stream which we are pre-taping today for
scheduling issues I'm Zach Weissmuller
and today we're going to be discussing
the unexpectedly strong showing by
Javier melaye in Argentina's
presidential Open primary election last
week in which he was the top vote getter
with 30 percent ahead of the 28 for the
center right party 27 for the center
left party although we can talk more
about those particular labels in a
minute and how accurate they are or are
not in this context but melee is the
figurehead for La libertad avanza party
which roughly translates to Liberty
advancing or Freedom forward and has
described himself as a Libertarian and
an Austrian Economist and
anarcho-capitalist
his opponents and many in the media have
described to him in quite different
terms but we're here today to sort all
that out
joining me today to discuss the ascent
of melee and libertarianism in Argentina
and Latin America more broadly will be
Gloria Alvarez she's wrapping up another
call but she's going to jump in here in
a minute she's an author and a radio and
TV host in Guatemala who has declared
that she's running for president on a
Libertarian platform there
also here right now is Eduardo Marty an
Argentine Economist who founded and ran
Junior Achievement Argentina for decades
to help create young entrepreneurs in
the country he currently runs the
foundation for intellectual
responsibility and supports malay's
candidacy for presidency thank you for
being here Eduardo my pleasure thank you
for asking me
uh great well first let's get this out
of the way uh for everybody who has
noticed yes
Malay and uh reasons own Nick Gillespie
do share a certain fashion sense and uh
hairstyle although uh we got a little
bit Messier hair with Malay he mentions
in an interview that he never Combs his
hair uh instead he gets out of the
shower dries it with a towel and then
lets the Invisible Hand comb it for him
so you know Malay is a he's a character
he's
um an interesting uh you know politic
Society he's got this kind of wild
almost uh Jester like bad boy Jester
Persona from what I can tell and we're
gonna play a bunch of clips that have
been circulating on social media of him
so that you can get a sense of all that
but before we get into it uh Eduardo do
you have any thoughts on the
presentation and image of Javier Malay
uh how is he perceived uh like based on
his media appearances is uh how's he
perceived in Argentina I I think your
description is very accurate he said bad
boy a wild guy but he's seen us
I don't know if you remember the Charles
Bronson Series where a Justice guy uh
that is not part of the law uh comes to
society to do justice in a context where
our politicians in Argentina have
managed themselves to destroy the
country for decades so the
hyperinflation process that we are
suffering right now is over 120 percent
a year and the the incredible poverty in
a country that produces food for for 400
million people
took people to a position where they
cannot believe how a potential rich
country become Who and the the kind of
suffering they are under so right now a
guy who comes and tells you that the
problem of Argentina is a Caster a group
of politicians that is just robbing them
and he's just creating all these bad
conditions related to uh
manipulation
manipulation of the currency taxis we
have 100 more than 160 taxes debt the
countries always borrowing money and
begging for money to different
institutions around the world so that
whole created a sense of decadence and
people are tired are suffering hunger
are in very very poor situations so when
a young guy comes and explains with
pretty good arguments the the situation
is caused by big government and that
government is not the solution but is
the institution that is creating this
but performance of the country
so he become very popular and he does it
in a very funny way he's very aggressive
speaking but he's knowledgeable compared
with some other politicians like Trump
or bolsonaro or some other ones in the
right in Europe he read a lot he read
Murray rodberg he read
um Ludwig for Mrs
he read kayak he Ray he read a Milton
Friedman so excuse me I just came from
Iceland and I took a cold
just taking a look to the country so
um melaye has become a very popular guy
and his style is like a rock star the
way he speaks and he knows how to argue
he's tough arguing and he doesn't have
any problem with a personal issues he
and if you try to
attack attack him on a dominant
arguments he knows how to answer so he's
a good polimist and the type of measures
he's suggesting to implementing the
country are the ones that any
libertarian any ocean Economist in in
some ways some objective is people also
uh would be happy with so in some other
areas not not so much he's a little bit
more conservative but the general
the average is pretty good for our
standard is fantastic and Incredibly
like Incredible Hulk coming to the
country so let's see if he can do it
first he needs to gain the presidency
yeah well let's talk a little bit more
about the beliefs of Javier Malay
because he does have very strong beliefs
you know you mentioned him in the
context of trump bolsonaro Orban uh
there's a tendency to kind of like lump
all these people together which I think
is a mistake and part of what we're
gonna disentangle a little bit here
um I watched a 2019 tedx talk that
melaye gave which was really an Ode to
capitalism uh we're gonna play a bit of
that and then discuss melee's
intellectual framework a bit more
um it'll be subtitled in Spanish and for
the audio only podcast I will overdub
this in English but here's Javier Malay
at tedx in 2019.
amor
ous
foreign
[Music]
jutto
so that's the button-down rational
sounding relay and he sounds very much
like a Libertarian Economist there we'll
get some of the spicier stuff soon but
Eduardo is a fellow Argentine
libertarian Economist what can you tell
us about malay's economic ideas well at
the beginning he was an economy
econometry economic econometrist so he
believed in planned models and just
studying statistics you can foresee what
the future would be so he was working
for corporations trying to give them
some kind of sense of where the markets
were going but without a solid base of
understanding I don't know Israel
kirsner or some Krishna or the good
Economist of explaining uh Hayek that
what is the dispersed knowledge in the
economy so he just he didn't have too
much knowledge related to it but once he
started to study Mrs Hayek Robert in
Argentina Venegas Lynch that he was a
promoter of Austrian economics so he is
little by little he started to believe
in the Market processes and it started
to buy them so
it's true what he's saying in his Ted
Talk what he's saying that he really
learned how the markets operate and also
he started to realize how capitalism
transformed the world in the last two or
three centuries so when he saw that what
he saw the effects of the Industrial
Revolution and he started to realize
that the type of life we live today a
consequence of changing ideas and a
little bit of John Locke a little bit of
Jefferson a little bit of Benjamin
Franklin a little bit of John Adams and
Alexis the talk wheel I don't think he
really read them in in deep but he got
that feeling in and after that Argentina
has been a fascist on socialist
socialist country for several decades
suddenly he discovered however that the
idea that necessity creates rights the
idea of social justice the idea that uh
that the wealth is fixed and when you
make money is at the expense of somebody
else
a kids start to discover that all those
ideas are wrong I don't know how deep
his knowledge is related to this
justice issues but I really think that
he has the proper sense of life he
become little by little a kind of
individualist
he is probably he's still a little bit
altruistic a little bit Mystic in uh
just in some approaches but
the sense of life is individualistic
he's in favor of
he if he if you ask him how to interpret
and defend property rights or he can do
it if he if you ask him about
um the your right to look for your own
happiness he knows how how it Justified
that so I think that compared with some
other politician he's a strong leader
understanding some issues his character
is too strong for my
my
pleasure the way he speaks he looks like
Benito Mussolini but still the the way
he approaches subjects is pretty good
let me interrupt here to say goodbye to
this gentleman thank you for coming stay
in touch sorry I'm back sorry no worries
well uh yeah so I mean that was spoken
you know like a uh true Unapologetic
Unapologetic uh objectivist you uh think
that you know some of his uh thinking is
a little too mystical not enough you
know grounded and uh that the the
philosophy of objectivism uh and I know
he does have
um you know a religious aspect uh to him
uh which we can talk a little bit more
about in a second as it pertains to his
social policy but I'm curious with his
uh you know his interest in mises and
Hayek and the Austrian School do you
have any idea how he came upon those
like is there a school in Argentina that
uh you know stresses the Austrian school
or did he just kind of yeah
Argentina is also liberal libertarian
country until
1926 that all Alberti and sarmiento the
main promoters of liberalism in
Argentina disappear and his ideas were
forgotten so in the 30s we had a coup
d'etat of military fascist militaries
very proportion and the idea of
nationalism remember that Argentina is
the eighth biggest country on earth a
very big country like the bigger than
Mexico and with in night night in 1890
we had I don't know two two million
inhabitants so Argentina after the
liberal constitution of 1853 and some
good precedencies liberal libertarian
presidents presidences attracted
millions of in and of in immigrants from
Italy from Spain from France from
Germany and suddenly a country like
Argentina went from two millions to 8
millions in a period of 30 years so in
Buenos Aires you had papers of all
different languages and from from three
men that you're speaking in the streets
of Buenos Aires two spoke different
languages but Spanish so
that arises a very nationalistic feeling
the idea of we need a kind of Putin
feeling and uh and the the autocrats in
Russia that become very nationalistic
the flag and uh started to develop that
kind of feelings and they were very
attracted to towards fascism Benito
Mussolini's idea with so many Italians
also immigrants and also the church when
the the church lost power in Argentina
after uh they were always in in control
of the state or at least very
influential when liberalism enter into
Argentina Church started to lose power
so
that created an alliance between
nationalism and the church what what we
call the nationalismo catholico that
happened in the 30s if you study
Argentina during the 30s to the 40s you
will find the creation of the central
bank that attacks their income tax
regulatory juntas for grains and
anything related to exports and imports
full of regulations increase taxes the
Whole Decade of the 30s not around the
world but in Argentina specifically
destroy all the liberal institutions
uh that created Perron Perron was an
admirer of Benito Mussolini was a kind
of fascist dictatorship and when he was
withdrawn by a revolution in 1955 uh the
whole country was infected by the
Pyrenees virus we we had become a kind
of collectivist country half Communists
have fascists but not liberals at all
this and that's what's known as that's
what's now known as peronism that that
kind of combination you're describing of
the two where it's a collectivist
ideology that uh it kind of mixes the
the two you know authoritarian
ideologies of the 20th century together
yeah and if you if you had the the com
the big component of the Catholic church
that after the reforms in Europe and
after secularizing versions of uh
governments around all Europe they took
Refugee where in Spain maybe Portugal
and Latin America so the whole ideas
that you'd cut you need to be povert if
you want to enter into heaven and the
idea that make money is a sin or the
idea that you need to sacrifice for your
fellow men and that the common good
should be superior to
of your individual good and social
justice and redistribution of wealth all
that was being
in force forward by the church you see
Fidel Castro you see all the Revolutions
in Latin America
forward by the church and you see right
now our Pope Mr bergoglio he is around
all dictators he doesn't speak bad of
Maduro he doesn't speak back Ortega he
is very good friend of the president of
Mexico
antisocialist policies he was a penalist
he is a penalist so he's in favor of
Christina kirsner so these are all the
yeah these so I mean these are all the
concepts that we hear Malay railing
against and I am going to take this
opportunity to add Gloria to the stream
because she uh just popped in hi Gloria
you're you're uh Mike's muted so just
there you go hello
Eduardo how are you
so we we just uh uh to open up the
stream we played a clip of of melee
giving a TED Talk in 2019 where he was
extolling the virtues of capitalism as a
an engine of prosperity and uh you know
uh uh uh welfare lifting all boats um he
sounded very much like a Libertarian
um Economist giving a lecture we you
know that's the kind of uh buttoned down
uh version of melee uh the way that he's
been portrayed here in by the Us Media
is I just pulled it together a little
Montage of headlines Argentinian far
right Outsider Javier melee posts shock
win in primary election in Argentina a
new Trump Rises
far-right populist Javier Malay is the
biggest vote getter in Argentina's
presidential primary New York Times
far-right libertarian so they did
describe as a Libertarian but a
far-right Libertarian wins Argentina's
presidential primary and then I just
want to dig into the New York Times
description of his policy positions here
for a second he says that they say that
besides his ideas about the currency and
the central bank which is something
we're going to get to later because
that's that's Central to the Malay
candidacy I think uh but they say he has
proposed drastically lowering taxes and
cutting public spending including
charging people to use the Public Health
Care System closing or privatizing all
state-owned Enterprises and eliminating
health education and environmental
Ministries
um you know uh I that that all sounds to
me like fairly straightforward
libertarian policy
um and uh the Spanish newspaper El Pais
had a rundown of uh some of his
positions on social issues
but uh marriage between people of the
same sex for me marriage was a contract
between private individuals says Millay
homosexuality sexuality has lived uh as
lived is a personal choice drug
legalization they say that Malay is in
favor of drug legalization because
consumption is an individual action uh
they say the same thing here about
gender identity uh malays kind of spicy
statement here is do you want to
perceive yourself as a cougar do it
doesn't matter to me as long as you
don't make me pay the bill don't impose
it on me from the state right
um he wants to deregulate the legal arms
markets which means allowing legal
firearms ownership
um he says he's not an advocate of the
military Argentine military dictatorship
although he is taking a look at what
buchelli is doing in El Salvador that
may or may not be of interest to him I
should also mention here that he uh
supports a referendum to undo
Argentina's recent abortion rights law
so he's anti-abortion he's also trying
to wage uh some of the same gender
studies schools fights that are raging
here in the U.S and last thing here is
he's expressed a
a natural alliance with figures like
Trump and Brazil's bolsonaro because he
says there he's on the side of anyone
against communism and socialism
um but I was saying earlier to uh
Eduardo that I I don't think it's
particularly Illuminating to say that
Trump equals bolsonaro equals Orban
equals Malay
especially because Malay
well we may have some criticisms of him
does look different from the rest but
Gloria what is your overall reaction to
the kind of far-right characterization
of Javier Malay well I think and and I I
agree with it a lot of that it is
important to understand Argentinian
history in order to understand the
massive ignorance that there is
especially in Latin America of what the
libertarian movement portrays for
example myself I was graduated from
universia Francisco Marroquin UFM I did
an internship at the cable Institute
I've dedicated my life for the
libertarian principles and to defuse
them not only in Latin America but
elsewhere in the world and now I have
people saying that I am not a
Libertarian because I don't want the
state getting involved in issues like
abortion gay marriage drug legalism
station opening borders not only to
products but also to people
they tell me that I have become a
Marxist because of this
so if I can fall into the category of
marxist because the understanding of
what libertarianism is in Latin America
is so vague of course you're gonna have
confusion all over the planet on one on
what Javier melaye portrays right
personally let's let's go every subject
that you touch because I think that if
we start focusing on policies instead of
focusing on individuals we dismantle the
populism that there is I don't like
analyzing politicians as dogmatic
Messiahs I like analyzing policies to
see how the policies are more or less
libertarian I think the more that we do
that the less fun a testament dogmatism
we're gonna have and I think we're in a
world that highly needs that for the
putins that also Narrows the trumps but
also the Chavez de Ortegas the the the
Evo Morales the lulas of the world we
have we have people going blindly after
people after leaders instead of going
very strict after policies with Javier
melaye says to you that gay marriage is
something he doesn't believe because he
doesn't believe that the state should
regulate marriage I say well then what's
the proposal gonna be it's a straight
marriage going to be something from the
past is he gonna take away the state in
every marriage
I don't think so right but it's a really
nice way of saying I'm not gonna touch
the issue so you know advancing in
sexual Liberty and Liberty to love
whoever you want to love in Latin
America I think is a huge one and also
differentiating that from using the
state to educate people and indoctrinate
people in things that you don't want
kids to be indoctrinated that's why the
state shouldn't get involved in
education because if the state is nasty
your kids are going to be Nazis if the
state is communism communist Etc and if
you go now to drugs when he says well
everybody is you know allowed to consume
whatever they want to consume that's
okay but drugs are not only about
consumption it's also about who is
producing them and we know as a fact
that the drug cartels from Colombia to
Fark to Mexico all the cartels have
Finance socialism of the 21st century
right it is one of the pillars and we as
Libertarians in the region have been
saying for decades that unless Latin
America
legalizes de criminalizes the production
of these substances we are not going to
have transparent politics because it's a
super highway of financing all these
leaders without any accountability
without any transparency so when he says
everybody can consume whatever the hell
they want
he's also like retrieving himself as a
Libertarian into taking action in these
issues right now when you go to
Argentina people are super concerned
about inflation about wages so they tell
you you know what I don't care about the
gays I don't care about the drugs I just
want my money to be a a healthy money I
just want to do business in a healthy
way I want my savings to be you know
guaranteed and I understand that because
Argentina has one of the worst
inflations that you can have and when
the economy you know it's it's pushing
ahead then of course that you're gonna
be okay so that's where we need to ask
ourselves if Javier comes to power is he
going to have a Congress that will
support him into uh opening up to the
markets because Argentina currently is
one of the worst countries in the world
in the index of economic freedom so you
need to maybe dollarize it to open up to
new currencies including
cryptocurrencies which are big in
Argentina but they are illegal there's
there are two different uh prices of
dollars in Argentina the black market
one and the the one that the government
uses so even if in economy we have to
ask ourselves what is he going to be
capable of doing now regarding abortion
it is true that nowadays argentinians
conservative argentinians that support
Javier melaye and and other leaders like
him have paid more than 30 000 abortions
yearly with their taxes since abortion
was something that uh it started to be a
state
introduced or managed in 2021
uh from from the policy of 2020 December
2020 right so you're talking about 30
000 abortions yearly and Uprising so
when he says that he's gonna take that
back he could also have The Stance of a
Libertarian which are not understood in
Latin America because you can be a
Libertarian and be against the state
paying for abortions but taking away the
state so that the market offers them
unless we as a Libertarians communicate
properly what are the libertarian ideas
Javier melee and other leaders will be
portrayed by the media as super far
right now the last issue that I want to
discuss supporting Trump Urban bolsonaro
and Putin has become a one deal package
in Latin America and we have been called
not truly Libertarians when we and I
mean we like me Antonella Marty the
libertarian party of Spain or even
objectivists in Enron Center Latin
America where Maria Eduardo's sister
works when you say wait a minute I don't
think that Trump is is having
libertarian stance or bolsonaro you you
get crucified in social media and people
tell you that unless you are with them
you are not a truly libertarian so I
think that we have to understand what is
it that you know differentiates Javier
melee from uh Ronald Reagan Christian a
free market guy from like a true
libertarian and and I think the only way
of doing that is analyzing what
libertarian policy means
but so when I look at that list of his
stances on social policies I would agree
with you that you know the the abortion
issue is is a big wedge I mean that's a
wedge even uh within the American
libertarian movement there's there's
division on that topic um I think you're
saying that at the very least a
Libertarian could or you know you you're
you think that the correct libertarian
position would be no State funding for
abortion but allow people to uh you know
make their own decisions there is that
nonetheless yeah according to the
Encyclopedia of libertarianism which is
already from 2011. 30 percent of
Libertarians are pro-life what we would
call you know anti-abortion 70 are
pro-choice right which I think is also
us and ran accurately say you can have a
pro-life statement for abortion but even
in the pro-life Libertarians they do not
agree that you should criminalize women
and put them in jail because abortion
should be considered a crime there are
interviews
and people who support him and have said
that we should use the state and the
Machinery of the state to criminalize
women who go under abortion how does
that enter the umbrella of
libertarianism even by
anarcho-capitalist I I say to them how
is it that you don't want to state but
you're going to have a private police
that is going to persecute a women and
their on their uterus like how is how is
that going to work you know and they
don't have a straight answer but they
want to make abortion something that the
state criminalizes yeah and then just so
I understand on these other topics where
he seemingly is in alignment with
libertarian philosophy on drug use or
sexuality uh you're saying that
um you know he's saying he's okay with
drug use but not offering a policy like
we need to end the prohibition of drug
sales in Argentina or in the case of gay
marriage he
um you know saying people can do
whatever they want but he's not actually
advancing like a equal protection for
gay couples in Argentina is that I just
want to make sure I'm understanding your
point is that a correct summation
absolutely it's like you know we if
libertarianism is all about individual
rights equal for everybody right now in
Latin America the the lesbian gays trans
they do not have equal rights in markets
for example you cannot if you're not
married you don't have the benefits that
straight couple have in order to have
inheritance in order to go to a cell
phone company and get a family package
for all your family if you're talking
about two lesbians they don't get those
benefits in the market you know what I
mean so those are things that marriage
gives you individual rights for straight
people that right now the LGBT community
does not have I think that as a living
Italian you can move forward to that
even even if you say that marriage
shouldn't be something that the state
should regulate okay but let's be equal
to everybody and then your libertarian
platform should be let's get let's get
rid of straight marriage and let's make
marriage something that only the market
uh does but then what happens you cannot
you can have a celebration of a gay
wedding but you cannot use you know
lawyers uh or or anything to protect
your rights that is the thing in Latin
America the same with prostitution
say well there's the sexual Market you
can do whatever you want but if you
don't decriminalize prostitution
prostitution keeps being something that
the black market market operates in
criminalization is is like if in the
United States during the prohibition you
would have a candidate saying Hell
people can drink whatever alcohol they
want to but he's not willing to end the
prohibition
what do you think of that critique
Eduardo uh and after this we're going to
bring in a couple more melee Clips so
that our our audience can really get a
sense of you know the kind of rhetoric
that he uses to to advance his ideas but
what do you think of Gloria's critique
of malay's you know social positions
that maybe he kind of throws a bone to
Libertarians but he's not actually
advancing policies that are going to
increase social freedom in Argentina
think that Gloria is
right
they need a need a perfect description
of the way Javier thinks
optimistic I think he was a kind of
middle of the road a little bit
collectivist and he started to
understand the benefits of individualism
and liberalism five years ago and he's
smart
he's very passionate and in order for
him to become popular also and learn
he became very close to people like
Nicolas Marquez or Mr blocky or Mr
Venegas Lynch Venegas Lynch was friend
of Lionel Reed the founder of foundation
for economic education and was the guy
who created the center for studies on
Liberty in Argentina he was printing the
Freeman he was the first one in printing
economics in one lesson Human Action
socialism so he was the liberal in
Argentina the father of what is right
now become the hero of the Libertarians
in Buenos Aires
he is an ocean Economist and he's very
consistent and he knows how to
articulate knowledge very well but he
has been a little bit conservative
regarding drugs regarding all social
issues and regarding also the abortion
but Forex I think that Javier little by
little not because of principles because
he didn't have the time to learn deep
principles I think but because of his
smells I think his sense of life is is
conservative but he's becoming more an
individualist
regarding abortion for example his last
declaration he last speech says that
okay I will not
penalize abortion I'm not in favor of
that but I want to stop financing
abortions and that could become a little
bit very consistent with the libertarian
ideas I don't know if maybe his next
declaration is going to say the same but
it seems that he's running little by
little
way of uh of conservatives but at the
same time I'm afraid that that can also
happen with economic principles the idea
of closing the central bank that for me
is a great idea the idea of reducing all
taxes we had 167 taxis and he suggested
to stay with six or seven taxes to
reduce
the size of government to 20 percent of
the PBI expenditures so all that he has
been very aggressive very consistent but
for example his last declaration he said
that he doesn't want to keep financing
the corn he said the science research
and the whole country went after him
saying you are going to stop financing
research in science and culture things
that are so so important this is a
broken country with people making I
don't know three thousand dollars a year
so with people searching in in the
garbage to eat you have 45 50 percent of
people in poverty so a good president
would come and say we are going to cut
all expenditures we will have a healthy
money and a very very short and budget
so we
we are trying to advise Javier that if
we really gain the presidency
to just to act on principle just a very
small government very consistent and not
enter into those social issues that
Gloria described so well his mind he's a
guy who's suffering his infancy a lot he
was being beaten by his parents and he's
he's full of
uh I don't know emotions that overflowed
him but I uh you know you know politics
is of course maybe one day we'll have
glorious president of Guatemala
influencing all that in America that
happens one day I will be there but and
I think that's really possible because
little by little we grow I don't know I
will be able to see it but they have
expectations but for the moment if you
compare Malay with
I don't know uh Patricia Burridge or the
candidate for the Christian Academy Mr
Masa you see a guy with a different
sense of life I resent also some of his
conservative positions and I think that
of course they are going they are not
going to help him to in his position but
compare what what we had in the past is
is is something I mean I yeah I I think
that that that emotion and passion that
you're talking about is partly what has
caught interest of a lot of
international Watchers a lot of people
here in the U.S I mean his rhetoric has
caught the interest of Americans I think
in part because he's speaking in a kind
of bombastic style that Taps into the
kind of you know us versus them
tribalism that's on the rise here I want
to take a quick look at a rant he went
on against leftists who he says have
ruined Argentina's economy
is
mierda
it's an intense captivating clip uh do
you agree with his sentiment that in
Argentina you can't negotiate with the
leftist Coalition because they'll use
the state apparatus to squelch that
debate and take everything away from you
um
connect can I go all right go ahead I
absolutely agree all over Latin America
when the left
on the in the elections they completely
destroyed the country we have seen it in
Chile we have seated in Colombia we've
seen it also in in Brazil with the
support to Lula so the left is obsessed
with with ruling from democracy when
they win or by making a lot of uh
um by making the
violence in the in the streets I I also
agree with how melee communicates
because he's engaging for decades we
have seen Libertarians uh saying well
yeah we have the right ideas but no
passion at all and here comes a guy with
a lot of passion but uh that's also a
thing that it's uh different uh and in
how it's perceived because for example
if you go to the videos that I recently
made in Guatemala's election that was
two days ago like like in this video
right where I go to vote and I say both
of our of my options are are socialists
and they are crap both of them in a
language that is very confrontative
maybe not in the same decibels as Javier
melee now if you go to the comments of
Javier melaye's interventions because he
is a man he's portrayed as what a leader
what an impelling way to communicate now
when a Libertarian woman does that it's
like you need to go to the psychiatrist
you're insane you get portrayed as why
are you communicating in such a
passionate way it's not seen the same
way you know with men
yeah with women it's like you you are a
crazy witch which I think it's not you
know it's not fair and people should ask
why do I allow this in Javier melee but
not in glory Alvarez or or whatever
other women are out there you know
spreading the ideas of Liberty like in
ladies of Liberty that's one thing now
there are other things that I want to
take out from that uh message cultural
battle
cultural battle has become like this
buzzword in uh in politics now I think
that Libertarians worldwide and here I
go again let's go back to the ideas
does the battle
is the battle about culture can you
battle a culture because if we
understand what culture is it's a
dynamic process an evolutionary process
where spontaneous order has high abuse
to say just happens so you cannot battle
a culture cultures are dynamic in my
understanding of what I've studied about
libertarianism the Battle Is about ideas
you can battle with ideas and if you
have the better ideas in a past in a
peaceful Society you can demonstrate
that your ideas are better now the fact
that we are adopting terms like cultural
battle worries me because this is
exactly what the Nazis or the fascists
did they want to state to to implement a
culture by law a culture of hatred uh
and then he says we are morally Superior
than the than this than the Shiri
socialists
that libertarianism is morally Superior
hell objectivism is morally Superior
because it it tells you that individuals
are not animals of sacrifice to the
state or the church now
Libertarians I can say are morally
Superior because they you know defend
the individual when Javier melaye adopts
conservatism religious Estates and he
talks about a moral superiority
I am worried if he is going to use the
state in order to implement one kind of
culture so what are we talking about
there and he even says we are
aesthetically Superior because he says
that people in the libertarian movement
are are more pretty than all these women
uh in the marxists collectivists that
are not even like shaving their legs or
whatever and I'm like yeah okay yeah the
market makes us prettier but those are
libertarian stands so then again I think
now that Javier melee is taking
International protagonism
we have a massive opportunity to educate
people in the United States and in Latin
America of what libertarianism is about
so if he governs and when he governs we
can be very very accurate because when
I'm worried what I really don't want it
to happen is that if he comes to
Governor government and he betrays
Liberty
people will blame Liberty instead of
blaming him which is what happened with
Pinochet it's been a headache for
Libertarians all over the region to to
you know like take ourselves away from
that Pinochet dictatorship which was a
capitalist dictatorship and and as Mario
vargasiosa said there is no such thing
as a good dictatorship and a bat
dictatorship all are bad so I am very
worried that if Libertarians don't take
this opportunity worldwide if he comes
into power and Liberty is betrayed
people will blame neoliberalism
capitalism when when they are not the
ones to be blamed you know yeah I mean I
I think you're you're absolutely right
about that and I hope that doesn't
happen
um it is interesting to hear him frame
Liberty or freedom in moral and
aesthetic terms because this goes back
to the Ted Talk we played at the
beginning he touches on on that and he
says you know when you look at a free
Society you look at the kind of
architecture and so forth that it
produces its Superior to what planned
economies produce therefore it's
aesthetically Superior so it's a very
it's an interesting argument that I
don't think is is made very often by
Libertarians and it might be something
you know worth thinking about but to a
glorious Point Eduardo uh you know this
fear that you know he that if he comes
to power he'll be the next Pinochet and
you know he's made these friendly
comments towards bolsonaro though he's
also said he doesn't support uh you know
bolsonaro's kind of whitewashing of
torture and so forth but are you worried
about that are you worried that that
could come to Bear if he wins the
presidency that he's gonna
Embrace uh authoritarian tactics have
you seen anything that indicates that
that's a concern
Implement
authoritarian tactics
can always be the Temptation there but I
think that probably his sense of life
that's my impression is still better
than his rhetoric in some ways when you
push him when when you push him in just
in there and you you point out his
contradictions he Retreats I think a
little bit and he's cautious so he I
think that his concept of freedom in
general the idea that do what you want
but don't bother me don't Don't Step on
me that idea is in his mind so in
general I don't think he will be tempted
to implement uh
politics that go to conculcate freedom
I I think that he will be a little bit
absorbed by the the
general climate a kind of Osmosis you
know Borges that has been a very famous
writer in Argentina used to say that
freedom is the space a soul needs
so if your soul is not very well
developed you will ask for a big
government to take care of your
responsibilities Argentina is in the
middle of it like most of Latin America
so some guys have become a little bit
individualistic and you see people
responsible for themselves that they
understand that to be happy is your own
responsibility and to develop your ego
and your your is it's up to you and I
think that there is another half that
still they are little childs that asking
uh who are putting all the
responsibility of the government I think
that in that way Javier is closer than
us than
the rest of the people so
I maybe because I want to be optimistic
I really I'm going to vote him for him
and I really expect that we can have
some influence on him the risk of
failure is always there
and he will be under attack right now
he's under attack in this moment we are
just having a conversation
in a neighborhood 10 minutes away from
here Recoleta downtown Buenos Aires they
are just attacking supermarkets because
of the hyper inflation Etc and because
as a kind of reaction for the
possibility of having uh Javier Miller
as president they try to create a
climate of Revolution if this guy comes
into the presidency we will make a fire
of the city of the cities in Argentina
so that's what climate does for not to
allow him to reform economic or take
economic measures is here already so
it's going to be a very tough battle not
only to try to conform a decadent
country into a prosperous economy but
also as Gloria said the risk of just
a guy become a conservative and try
instead of just forward Liberties to be
cautious about them I think I think that
the a better percentages in our side
you know um that's uh that's disturbing
to hear that that uh action is unfolding
on the street in the the wake of the
primary right now and um you know
there's I I think we should move the the
final portion of the conversation here
to discussion of those issues that kind
of are motivating people to get out on
the streets the the issues that kind of
led to malays rise which I think uh are
largely the economy the Central Bank um
and the way that the political class or
I think as you put it the the cast that
uh is the way Malay frames it I've got
I've pulled one more clip that I think
will take us into that discussion which
um is uh belay uh again uh directing a
lot of passion and anger with very
heated rhetoric but in a direction that
I think a lot of Libertarians would
agree is warranted at corrupt political
Elites so let's take a look at this and
discuss
cultural
foreign
monarcas
is
so I mean the person who first shared
that clip with me commented that it
almost seems ripped from the pages of an
Iran novel I want to start with Gloria
this time but Eduardo you can share any
thoughts too just what are your
reactions to melee's message there I
absolutely agree I actually I have said
the same thing in different words in
many forums because in Latin America the
majority of people do not understand
that the government doesn't produce
wealth there is a misconception that the
government is sort of like a magic
spaceship where money is magically
created and the politicians Grant you
with resources and money that magically
they possess you know people do not get
the basic idea that every cent that the
government has is because they have
taken even violently from the people who
produced it so if you don't understand
that the politicians are your employees
and you think that they are the kings
that Grant you rights and Grant you
resources of course you blindly obey to
whatever they they are going to say and
of course the politicians are going to
have a commission mentality because that
technician mentality is the one that
grants them all the powers to control
the economy it is really rare to have a
politician that is going to have a free
market approach so I I absolutely agree
and about
um politicians being sociopaths I've
said this multiple times I think that we
need to have uh not only analyze our
politicians by the resume but we should
also have them for what Eduardo said
emotional intelligence tests
psychological tests because I believe
that Latin America has been governed by
narcissists and sociopaths and I always
say when people tell me because of the
way that I express myself right that
they say oh you you have mental problems
and I'm like yeah I am you know like I I
have no problem to be you know tested in
in Psychology tests or MRI or whatever
but just please make it very neutral
because if you put me with conservative
shrinks or with social strings of course
they're gonna declare me crazy right but
I do believe that emotional intelligence
is something that the world needs in
their leaders you know and not only in
Latin America worldwide it is something
that is highly needed a mandatory psych
evaluation to run for office would I
think really clear out the existing uh
class of politicians around the globe
but Eduardo what I uh um notice in that
clip is that he's talking in terms of
class Warfare but instead of kind of
traditional Marxist class Warfare It's
the political class versus the rest of
the working versus you know the the
productive class what do you what do you
think of that framing that he's putting
forward is is that a good message for
Argentina and is it resonating I I think
that is it's it's good that people
become reluctant uh I they they develop
a reluctant a reluctant attitude towards
politicians I think that's always good
uh I think that the real problem is
again in in the mind of the people ideas
I think that if you read Lori sanata for
example Lori sanata is a Bolognese that
writes about the influence of the church
in Latin America and how we developed
those socialist redistributive ideas
social justice the idea that necessity
creates rights from a specific spectrum
of people that are in favor of altruism
sacrifices big government and that you
need to sacrifice yourself for the
common good if that idea is there always
we always will have politicians just
instrumenting those ideas so the real
fight the big fight is in the minds of
philosophers and that's why we approach
in general objectivism or the the if you
read Stephen Hicks explaining
post-modernism and that idea of you have
all the post-modernist the Germans and
the French from can to Hegel from Hegel
to Marx heideggery fixed
and the French
you read all that influence and that
influence really
Worcester within Latin America the
church profits from that so you created
guilty complex where the society didn't
have they don't have the instruments to
defend themselves so
the politicians appear and they make you
feel guilty and we need you are not
going to you are being a selfish God you
are not going to give up your fortune to
in order to improve society and if you
have that kind of mentality and the guys
in the church are the good guys in
anyone trying to make money for for your
own family and for your future you
become a selfish son of a so
therefore there is it's very difficult
to fight that fight so politicians are
the result of this kind of mentality
that with Princess like Gloria fighting
all around Latin America just spreading
out good principles and some good
intellectuals we are trying to give the
fight but I think you need to give that
fight over in the states it's not
completed yet you had very good
intellectuals but you see in the
universities you still we have in
Harvard in Berkeley and different
universities some leftists intellectuals
the American sense of life is very
individualistic that's why you you keep
progressing but it's a fight that is
involving all of us I think politicians
is good for us to put our eye in
politicians and try to control them in
that way
very simple way I think Malay is giving
a service to the country with all the
shortcomings we mentioned here but in
general I think that has been a step
forward for the country that has been so
bad treated for the last decades so
let's take a look very quickly at the
degree to which this message is starting
to catch on in Argentina this is from a
public uh polling Source in Argentina
and as always we link all the sources in
the description and the page at
reason.com but this yellow line the Gold
Line is going up from 2020 to 2020 uh
from 2021 to 2022 at the expense of the
two competing parties obviously we know
what happened in uh 2023 last week uh
where he overtook them this breaks down
the support for Javier melee by
political affiliation and and you see a
stark divide obviously the Libertarians
in strong support of Javier Malay you
know upwards of 80 percent support
um when you go to the center right party
which is the fourth row down
um that that's you know hovering around
40 percent and then the kind of left
party uh you know sharp drop off below
20 and then no support uh measurable
support whatsoever among the Socialists
left also perhaps uh unsurprising but in
that kind of situation where there's
such Stark division polarization and
fracturing and you know say melee wins
um he's only going to win with a you
know maybe not even a majority maybe a
slim majority under those circumstances
where he still has to govern in a
coalition government how optimistic are
you that he can get the please rather
you know uh aggressive agenda items
through in Argentina
go ahead okay go ahead Gloria
um well I don't know how things are
gonna be on ground when people
when people dress
my strategy would be once in office if
people have elected you because of these
proposals which I've divided in
non-negotiable and ten that are you know
negotiable for people to choose five if
I start being blocked with one of those
five I would just go back to the people
who voted for me and elected me and be
like hey guys I need your support
because these politicians are not
letting me you know Advance on the
things that I promise you now I would
have the attitude of Margaret Thatcher
like I am not here to please everyone I
am here to do the right job and if the
other politicians and the other
coalitions do not let the ideas of
Liberty advance in my personal case I
would just uh quit and leave office
because otherwise you start compromising
and compromising until your government
is another mediocre right-wing
government that doesn't do anything for
the region like we've seen with macri
with Duke with Pinera and then when the
left comes back
people say you see near neoliberalism
doesn't work capitalism doesn't work and
it's like no you didn't let these ideas
to be implemented in the first place uh
and that's that's I think my concern
more than than others that if this
project and Libertarians around the
world do not take this opportunity to
really communicate to people what
libertarianism is about if Javier relay
gets blocked people won't blame Javier
melee they will blame libertarianism and
then again we will have other 20 years
of trying to you know uh take take the
real good ideas out of that
misconception
well what what does seem to be driving
to a large degree the melee phenomenon
is this extreme inflationary situation
that Argentina is facing you mentioned
at the top Eduardo triple digit
inflation
um this is a article I pulled up from
Daniel race back at the Cato Institute
arguing that Argentina should dollarize
Pronto and that's also Central to
melee's platform that basically shut
down the Central Bank convert to Dollars
allow people to use cryptocurrency more
easily and down at the bottom of this
you'll see that uh 50 that everyone
across the board seems to rank inflation
as the country's worst problem 59 among
the leftist Coalition 67 percent among
the center-right opposition I assume
much much higher among the Libertarians
uh you know I have one last clip that
I'm going to play to kick off this
discussion about uh Central Banking and
malay's plan to dollarize the economy
where Malay is is laying it all out so
let's listen to what he has to say and
then Eduardo I'd like to have you react
to the plan that he's put forward
foreign
porque
porque for social local inflationary
companies
foreign
so first of all I'll just say that he
demonstrates a better understanding more
competent understanding of Bitcoin than
just about any politician that I've
heard talk about it
with the issue of the central bank
that's really the kind of first order of
business for him would be to shut down
the central bank and dollarize the
economy just in case our listeners are
not clear on what that means it means
that U.S dollars would be the accepted
currency in Argentina and it's something
that's been done in other countries
Panama El Salvador I believe Ecuador so
what what are you what do you think
about that aspect of melee's plan
well first of all I would say that uh
Central Bank was created in 1935 with
the idea of lender of Last Resort and
what they really did the politicians in
Argentina they have been financing the
government at the expense of the middle
class and the whole class in Argentina
we had an average rate of inflation of
over 50 percent a year since 1935 we cut
13 zeros to our money and we still this
year will we will have to cut another
two because one dollar right now is 700
pesos three months ago was half of it so
the inflation rate we are we are just in
the process of and the third or fourth
hyperinflation process in Argentina so
the idea of closing the central bank is
very attractive because has been used to
promote government to allow our
opportunity politicians to build I don't
know Versace the Paleo versages all
around to buy planes and to live a very
good life what Javier is proposing is
the idea of just dollar Ice in the
economy I think if if you are going to
impose another currency I would suggest
that go back to Gold like Murray Rover
suggested just in the mystery of banking
where why dollar and a currency that is
suffering seven eight percent of
inflation per year and also is in in the
hands of some other politicians that
maybe they are not so corrupted as ours
but all but they are always tempted to
print money and you see by the current
deficits you run in the states so I
think what is important is to eliminate
the Corso forsoso the idea of that you
really need to use this money Amelia is
in favor of that so he's in favor of 100
Reserve banking not to Ally secondary
the issue of secondary money to the
banks and I think that's going to work
of course it's going to be tough just to
get out of inflation to a healthy
currency is going to take time it's not
going to be made in one or two years and
let's see the reaction of the public and
of course is going to be boycotted so
the situation is going to be tough but
Argentina cannot live another year with
this hyperinflationary process where 50
percent of the population cannot eat in
a country this like Ukraine it's like
Brazil we produce food and we are very
good producers of food so it's
inevitable I think the the closing of
the you will see I think that because of
all these situations you will see Javier
melaye as our next president let's see
if he's allowed to govern and let's see
if he has a career marriage and he has
the character to implement the good
measures and I hope that the social
aspects conservative aspects of Javier
he he he restricts himself to push
legislation
to Collective legislation I hope that he
really leave that part aside and we can
enjoy it after eight years or 90 years
of collectivism a good government for
argentinians we deserve it I think that
it's time for us to live a little bit
with a little bit of quiet and peace
could you give us a sense of just what
it's like living under those economic
conditions I mean uh both the
hyperinflation you know Americans for
the first time in my lifetime
experienced some uh inflation that that
we could feel year over year in recent
years but it's nothing like what's going
on in Argentina and you're you know a
GDP from I think 2010 to 2021 there was
no growth economic growth so what is it
like uh just day to day
um living under those conditions when
you go to a supermarket they they they
instead of giving you a price you need
to scan because they are changing the
prices of time you have 10 this this
month they say they will have the
inflation rate will be 25 percent so if
the prices are not available
cost of rebuying the item for the public
so sometimes they stop selling you and
you start to see that merchandises all
the the Commerce goes down so do you see
a situation where you don't have credit
I sold a Terrain I have in a country
club near here Buenos Aires and let's
suppose that you sell it for 300 000. so
they give bring the money to you
today to the place that and they you
have to count 300 000 bucks right there
you don't transfer through banks you
need to use cash and of course you can
be robbed you can be so anytime you do a
transaction the whole track said you
don't have credit if you want to buy a
house you need to buy the house cash of
course that's impossible and of course
the whole Commerce is resented by that
it's a cause the economy stops is like
in Atlas rank when you see that lights
went down and things shrink and people
are unhappy and they everybody works
like this and you have you can you
cannot see a future and people are just
nervous all the time they become manga
crime starts so we need to stop that and
also there is no certainty in prices in
Argentina last year when I was there if
you go to any store nothing has a fixed
price for example if you want to buy
this cup it's all about are you going to
pay it in cash in six payments 12
payments is it going to be with a check
is it going to be with a credit card
it's going to be with a debit card and
depending on that the cup can cost you
one two three ten dollars twenty dollars
so imagine that multiply by everything
in the economy there's no certainty
whatsoever you cannot plan anything in
in that uncertainty
yeah and uh I mean that's it's that
sounds like just a horrific the the
uncertainty you know day-to-day
uncertainty is just one of the worst
things for uh just human Prosperity
human flourishing not to not be able to
know just something as basic as how much
money you're gonna need to spend and you
know budget for that week and hopefully
Javier malays rhetoric will it if he
wins we'll we'll match the reality and
and some sort of you know Market
mechanisms and discipline will be able
to like turn this around for Argentina I
do want to wrap up by zooming out of
Argentina for a moment with
um Gloria this I want to talk about this
Dynamic of socialism Rising causing
economic destruction Paving the way for
the kinds of reactions that you have
expressed concerned about
manifesting as right-wing military
dictatorships which then kind of begins
to cycle over again it seems to happen
continually all over Latin America and I
assume it's a cycle you're trying to
break what do you think the key to
breaking it is and how optimistic are
you that it can be done
I do believe the answer is embracing
individual liberties and economic
Liberties as one like and run said many
decades ago conservatism and obituary uh
they they're far right in Latin America
is mercantilist they don't want free
markets they don't want to discuss uh
drug cartel used to finance socialism of
the 21st century they don't want to talk
about open borders they don't want they
don't want freedoms period they just
want to have their uh private property
protected in ways that were very similar
to the Southern economy of the United
States previous to the Civil War let's
let's understand that right and I
believe that that's not the way that's
why young people go to the left wing
because the left wing has disguised
themselves as feminists LGBT
environmentalists all these flags that
of course they don't defend in reality
right but but young people are attracted
to that my country after three
right-wing governments that have been an
absolute disaster masters of corruption
from Otto Perez Molina Jimmy Morales and
jamate finally because of three really
bad right-wing governments now we have
socialists with Mia and I've been saying
that asan ran you know like conservatism
and obituary guys you know it's gonna
happen to us and people are like no no
the left wing is not going to govern
Guatemala until now it does so I believe
that that's the only way embracing
libertarian ideas and I believe that
what Javier Miller is doing in Argentina
it's a massive opportunity for
libertarianism worldwide to really make
a stance on what is it that we believe
right and defending those ideas like
Hayek did in road to serve them from the
Nazis and the fascists and the
Communists all equally you know not not
uh not just in in one side
yeah uh and it's you know he's got quite
the task ahead of him if he does win
because of all we've mentioned with all
the the violence that uh Eduardo said is
already pouring out into the streets
um so you know it's not going to be for
the faint of heart Eduardo I want to ask
you you know the general election is
scheduled for October 22nd of this year
and Malay is going to face off against
one candidate from each of the two other
major parties and he has to either win
45 percent of the vote on the first
round or 40 percent of the vote if he
beats them both by at least 10 points
otherwise there'll be a runoff
How likely do you think it is at this
point melee can pull it off
oh I believe
I believe that when an idea has has come
the time for an idea to run to to impose
itself I think that it happens and I I
think we have been fighting the fight
for freedom for decades so little by
little through the university Etc I
don't
a strong group of intellectuals react to
that and I think that right now it's a
small group but it has had enough
influence to allow the appearance of a
politician like a volcanoes that really
is leading this fight which show
comments as we mentioned before but I
think it's a very good opportunity to
allow argentinians to live a better life
so I think that one third one third one
third the last election I think that
he's gonna win I I trust that he's going
to win
and then we have two more elections the
first one would be for the presidential
election but if none of them get 45
percent of the votes or at least 10
percent difference the the last two will
run in the last one in November I think
that will be a melee against probably
bullridge or Masa and I think he's gonna
win he's going to win the next president
of course all the Casta politica is just
just creating a climate of destitution
saying that we are going to do what
happened with Castillo in Peru because
we have the Congress and we have the but
I don't think that's going to happen I
think that
melaye will become a can of uh
uh mix of bouquet with I don't know
let's see let's see but I'm pretty
optimistic I think that uh he will
change things he will be able to he has
a personality he's a young man like
Gloria is a young lady they still have
the energy and the courage to go Against
All Odds so I think that's going to be
the beginning of a change in Latin
America with the intellect we have to
back them and give them arguments and
help
if he does pull it off what are your
obviously there's a lot of work to be
done as we've laid out in the Stream but
what is your your best hope for the
immediate future of Argentina
well I think that uh if we the first
thing is to analyze the budget to reduce
it at least immediately in a 10 percent
uh the monetary fund the international
model they request a reduction of the
budget to four or five points I think
that they should reduce 20 or 30 you
need to reduce the bureaucracy the
Ministries the all the activities the
government does to close secretaries to
close uh and I think it's going to do
that in several aspects the monetary
reform the labor reform we have a
fascist system that gives a lot of
privileges to the to unions he promised
to change that too and if he cuts a
budget he does a monetary reform he
opens the economy we have all the
empress audios a word that Gloria
created and spread out all around Latin
America then press serious in Argentina
they are big Mafia groups and all those
always putting a lot of pressure on any
president they don't want to open the
economy I think that he will do his best
to for that happens and in Argentina is
going to be very very important the
reducing taxes also
um the
eliminating regulations I think that we
are helping with a group of guys in the
educational aspects to see if we can
change
indoctrination coming from the states in
all public state universities and we are
just helping to organize law projects to
change that too so there is a lot to be
done I think that the pressures are
incredible and the the you only have
four years so let's see what he can do
for me is after many that was a Pyrenees
government pretty libertarian is the
first opportunity in the last 20 years
to see that maybe we have we have the
hope that something will change so I'm I
am supporting him with my eyes open as
Gloria said trying to correct what I
think is wrong and trying to push what I
think is right but it's a good
opportunity for Argentina and I think
that has also will have a some influence
on the right of Latin America let's see
yeah well we'll we'll certainly be
watching over yeah we'll certainly be
watching over here and uh you know
hopefully uh bringing you back on to get
some updates uh as uh the election
unfolds and you know other uh
libertarian movements uh see gain
Traction in Latin America uh before we
go uh Gloria is there anywhere that uh
people should look for you or support
the work that you're doing in Guatemala
I need as much help I can get from all
the Libertarians around the world to
communicate what libertarianism is all
about you can find me on Tick Tock
Facebook Twitter Instagram YouTube
telegram as Gloria Alvarez and uh I
think this is a great opportunity to
spread our ideas and and and present
them as a coherent offer for a region
that is highly disappointed with what
has governed us so thank you very much
for this uh space sac and and Eduardo it
was such a pleasure to share with you
and talk about this
um I think that this is as I say
something that is challenging for us as
a movement to be you know uh watching
what's what's gonna happen so thank you
very much
thank you both of you Zach send us the
video so we can promote it in our
countries for sure absolutely uh this
will uh uh and thank you for everyone
who tuned in we will be back here next
Thursday at 1pm as always we will